the president just got done speaking as
he headed out to marine one this is tape
playback so he is already in the air but
he could see him walking over to the
pool well listen into this and then
stand by for his flight down to Norfolk
so to see what happens we want to get
our country back to work the doctors
nurses first responders everybody doing
a phenomenal job like beyond good I'm
going to as you know the comforts a
great ship comfort is stopped up through
the gills is right up to the top and
we're going over there and I guess some
of you are coming with me but we're
going to send that up to New York four
weeks ahead of schedule and it is loaded
up with everything so that's great I
just spoke with Governor Cuomo and he's
expecting it on Monday it'll take about
two days so we're very excited about
that but I'm gonna go see the people
that did the work because it was
supposed to take a good four weeks that
we did it in four days
barks you
you know I think free I think 3m has
done an incredible job I just spoke to
Ken Langone I think he's on the board of
3m he called up and he said what a great
job they've done I think 3m from
everybody what everybody said they've
done an incredible job
[Music]
look at that planning absolutely
we're gonna use I would say we'll use it
again maybe once or twice we have a
couple of little problem children and
we have to but overall I tell you these
private free enterprise system as it
worked like nobody's seen in a long time
it's a beautiful beautiful thing to
watch what kinds of supplies might be
you
new companies that have not lived up to
what they said I would say there were a
one percent group okay and now all of a
sudden they heard we're going to use it
and they're rolling out the red carpet
has a governor that you're not getting
along with well these concerns
oh I think really most of the governors
are very appreciative as I said I just
spoke with Andrew Cuomo I just spoke
with Ron de santis we're thinking about
certain things some people would like to
see New York quarantine because it's a
hot spot New York New Jersey maybe one
or two other places certain parts of
Connecticut quarantine I'm thinking
about that right now we might not have
to do it but there's a possibility that
sometime today we'll do a quarantine to
a term two weeks on New York probably
New Jersey certain parts of Connecticut
let strictly to travel from those places
we pick travel because they're having
problems down
New York is going down we don't want
that heavily infected we're having a
really good dialogue with Governor Cuomo
we've supplied them with a lot of things
we're giving them an extra for medical
centers tents that's beyond what we've
already given as you know we're giving
up the new jersey we're doing a great
job with the governor of new jersey it's
been very good this would be an
enforceable you know I'd rather not to
it but we may need it so I will see over
at the ship
[Music]